caped crusaders and awesome Avengers are
everywhere you look at the movies and
there's a great selection of
crowd-pleasing blockbusters that take
the format to new heights from 70's
classics to modern-day epics these are
the 30 best superhero movies ever made
this 2010 film based on the comic series
of the same name isn't your typical
superhero story and that's exactly what
makes it so great it's the story of a
kid who really has no business being a
hero but does it anyway with bone
cracking profane and over-the-top action
kick-ass proved to be a breakout project
for Aaron Johnson and Chloe grace Moretz
and when veteran weirdo Nicolas Cage is
involved how can you possibly go wrong
nevermind a kick-ass is great though
Chronicle gives the superhero genre the
found-footage treatment telling the
story of three teenagers who stumble
upon a mysterious extraterrestrial
object that grants them seemingly
limitless superpowers of course being a
teen is hard enough but being a teen
with telekinesis well that's too much of
a burden to bear and this superhero
origin story quickly turns evil a
surprise hit the movie resonated with
critics and fans alike sure there are
moments where you'll wonder why the
cameras are still rolling as psychic
high school students battle it out in
the sky but the movie is such a tense
thrill ride that you'll quickly forget
any flaws as the movie heads towards its
inevitable and horrific showdown big
hero 6 is a loose adaptation of a quirky
obscure Marvel comic and was one of the
best films of 2014 animated superhero or
otherwise it follows a kid whose brother
is tragically killed in a fire and how
he moves on from that loss by making
friends with his brothers robots and the
friends he left behind when they
realized there must have been more to
the fire than it seemed they suit up as
superheroes to get justice but not even
the film's villain is as cut and dried
as it might appear the visuals are great
too the tone is pitch perfect and
there's even a Stan Lee cameo Liam
Neeson has a special set of skills and
that usually involves playing dudes you
just don't mess with I'll see you when
you're sleeping
I know when you're awake but before he
fought human traffickers wolves and Lego
lawbreakers he was dark man this flick
finds Neeson playing Peyton Westlake a
scientist who becomes a scarred and
reluctant superhero beneath the layers
of monster makeup Neeson strikes the
perfect balance of madness righteous
anger and pathos notable for its bizarre
rage sequences clever practical effects
and can't be tone this 1990 flick feels
like a mashup a Batman Evil Dead 2 and
the Phantom of the Opera if you're tired
of the usual Marvel and DC fare this
film goes to weird and wacky places most
superhero movies would never dare
Hellboy is a 2004 film which follows the
titular half-demon memorably played by
Ron Perlman as he helps humanity take on
supernatural threats director Guillermo
del Toro's visual style is perfectly
suited to this story which follows
Hellboy as he tries to figure out just
exactly what he is while also battling
all sorts of baddies along the way the
effects work is out of this world and
the design of villains like the undead
clockwork Ronin is totally terrifying it
takes a special kind of magic to get
Hellboy right but del Toro and Perlman
possess exactly what it takes to give us
a devilishly good movie it's an absolute
miracle this blood-soaked
f-bomb drenched movie ever made it to
the big screen but heart we all glad it
did Deadpool lived in development held
for years and it took the leak of a
concept reel to finally jumpstart it the
results are quick filthy and fun with
Ryan Reynolds born to play the part the
Merc with a mouth now holds the record
for the highest-grossing x-men film and
the highest-grossing r-rated film in
history a magnificent conflict between
Sir Patrick Stewart's Professor X and
Sir Ian McKellen's magneto
2003 sx2 x-men United is considered by
many to be the best of the original
x-men trilogy and it just couldn't be
made today that energy and fierceness
has dispersed from popular imagination
replaced by the cynicism of Deadpool and
the grim pessimism of Logan doing
justice to its source material the 1982
masterpiece God loves man kills this
film is required viewing with 1989 s
Batman director Tim Burton managed to
take a Carriger best known for Adam West
penis and turn him into a serious hero
for comic book fans with the franchise's
staying power fading fast in the late
1970s it took more than a decade to
finally get a new adaptation mounted
many fans flew into an uproar over
Michael Keaton's casting in the title
role but one look at the final film made
all those worries melt away
Burton treated the Canon seriously and
though he didn't follow it note for note
he paid tribute to it and built a living
breathing version of Gotham City
combining the worlds of the original
x-men trilogy with the x-men prequel
sequel series was a tall order but Bryan
Singer pulled it off with his return to
the franchise after taking a break for a
couple of films Days of Future past
managed to weave together a story
spanning decades with two separate casts
and still keep all the story tight
enough so even someone who's never seen
an x-men film could follow along it also
stealthily retconned out the atrocious
x-men The Last Stand making all things
right with in the cinematic X universe
Batman Returns is less about Batman than
it is about the creation of Catwoman
played outstandingly by Michelle
Pfeiffer
meow it also happens to feature Michael
Keaton returning to his role as Batman
and Danny DeVito as a hideous version of
the penguin in a part written
specifically for him with Pfeiffer in
the catsuit Tim Burton at the height of
his directorial powers and Keaton's
willingness to let his smug yet charming
Bruce Wayne share the spotlight with two
formidable foes this sequel earned
praise from critics and became a
box-office hit in 2019 the DC extended
universe saw Ben Affleck hang up the bat
cape and Henry Cavill Superman was still
up in the air
even the runaway success of Aquaman
couldn't seem to save Warner Brothers
superhero franchise that's when Shazam
arrived to electrify audiences
Shazam tells the tale of Billy Batson a
kid who's granted Superman like powers
and the ability to transform into an
adult by an aging wizard the result is a
movie that strips away all the DC
darkness and gives us a film that's both
sweet and fun it's also a movie about
the importance of family and finding
your place in the world which is a lot
nicer than watching the Caped Crusader
murdering people on top of all that
Shazam has the right amount of weirdness
to make it stand out from the superhero
pack it isn't afraid to embrace its
oddball comic book origins and the
result is an absolute blast and
ultimately that's kind of the point of
the film it's really fun to be a
superhero
guardians of the galaxy earns its spot
by being a galactic joy to behold
bringing 70s arena rock and Marvel
superheroes to outer space Zoe Saldana
and chance as the green skinned Gamora
Bradley Cooper shows his impressive
range as the voice of Rocket Raccoon and
Vin Diesel's Groot makes three words
speak volumes Plus dave bautista Drax
the destroyer steals every scene nothing
goes over my head
my reflexes are too fast catch it before
Guardians the Marvel Cinematic Universe
had been pretty straightforward sure
there were fire-breathing dudes and Dark
Elves but this was a movie about a
talking tree a smart-aleck raccoon and a
whistling space pirate writer director
James Gunn pulled it off injecting those
losers and scoundrels with wits and
warmth we are all grouped in 1985
Sylvester Stallone tried bringing Judge
Dredd to the silver screen and the
result was an absolute disaster
I caused de-evolution fortunately the
mean-mugging lawmen got a second shot in
2012 when Karl Urban down the grungy red
helmet the plots of Dredd is incredibly
simple the world is a dystopian
nightmare and megacity one is crawling
with crime and Dredd and his psychic
partner have to clear out floor at the
floor of a skyscraper to bring down a
powerful crime lord the violence here is
surprisingly beautiful with slow motion
and vivid colors used to incredible
effect if graceful gory violence is your
thing then Dredd is required viewing
often described as Avengers 2.5 civil
war featured tons of Avengers and told a
politically charged story that set
Earth's Mightiest Heroes against one
another in an eye-popping big-screen
battle royale along with giving fans
high stakes heroes vs. heroes battles
Civil War also introduced Black Panther
to mainstream audiences and took a major
step toward moving the MCU forward by
picking over some of the fallout from
age of Ultron but even if you're not up
on all the Marvel lore it's still one
heck of a fun thrill ride more explosive
more affecting and funnier than the
first
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 is another
snarky space epic powered by a soulful
classic rock soundtrack and awesome
visuals this time around the Guardians
square off against Aisha High Priestess
of the sovereign and eventually the
godlike ego memorable performances from
Palm Clemente F Karen Gilliam Michael
Rooker Sylvester Stallone and Kurt
Russell also make this sequel a must-see
critics who quibbled with volume to
hyperactive style and emotional moments
missed one of the funniest movies of
Marvel's collection until 2017 Thor was
little more than a pompous prince who
liked hitting things with a hammer and
took himself way too seriously
Marvel just needed the right filmmaker
to turn this Asgardian into a likeable
guy
and they found it with Taika Waititi who
scaled back the Shakespearean theatrics
and turned Thor into a well-meaning
goofball I choose to run to warn my
problems and not away from them paired
with the nebbishy Bruce Banner Ragnarok
becomes an Odd Couple comedy and space
and the funniest film in the MCU add an
80s aesthetic the supercool score Thor
battling Hulk and a gladiator match and
a cast that includes Jeff Goldblum and
his strangest and all the problems out
of the Thor franchise are perfectly
hammered out the Winter Soldier is much
more than just the superhero movie it's
Marvel getting political Winter Soldier
finds her recently thought Steve Rogers
in a world where things aren't quite
black and white anymore it's hard to
know who to trust then cap quickly finds
himself in the middle of a conspiracy
that involves secret Hydra agents metal
armed assassins and worst of all an evil
Robert Redford with the fate of the
world hanging in the balance cap goes
rogue Winter Soldier features some of
the most suspenseful scenes you'll ever
see in a superhero film with tense
moments that boil over into fantastic
action scenes the film also shakes up
the MCU setting up the stakes for Civil
War Winter Soldier is a masterclass and
action intention and the best entry in
the Captain America franchise though the
big screen Superman is dark and dreary
these days he got his starts as a
brilliant red and blue beacon of hope
Richard Donner's 1978 Superman starring
Christopher Reeve was an instant classic
pulling in an a-list cast and telling a
classic story complete with a dastardly
Lex Luthor from the cutting-edge special
effects to the casting of the then
unknown Rivas Clark Kent superhero set
the template for the modern-day
superhero movies proving you could take
these characters seriously and still
have a whole lotta fun in the process
M night Shyamalan son breakable was a
brilliant exploration and deconstruction
of comic book characters at a time when
superhero movies weren't the juggernauts
of Hollywood they'd soon become and a
radical departure from the superhero
films that had come before
unbreakable treated superheroes
seriously laying the groundwork for many
comic-book movies to come plus the movie
just good Bruce Willis and samuel
l.jackson give outstanding performances
the score is incredibly haunting and the
film created a universe where James
McAvoy would someday unleash his inner
beast change was overdue in the MCU and
black panther pounced on to the scene
played by Chadwick Boseman T'Challa
first showed up in civil war and quickly
became a fan favorite the courageous cat
made his triumphant return in 2018 and
when his film hit theaters audiences
fell in love with what Conda
she never gets hard
[Music]
Black Panther is one of the
highest-grossing films of all time and
the first superhero movie to get an
Oscar nomination for Best Picture
talented actors like Lupita Nyong'o
Daniel Kuya and Angela Bassett struck a
chord with audiences and the African
setting allowed filmmaker Ryan Coogler
to explore a rich culture that's a
little seen in Hollywood films the film
also introduced one of the greatest bad
guys in superhero history Erick Gill
monger
played two villainous perfection by
Michael B Jordan kill monger is a stone
cold but sympathetic murderer with its
fantastic characters and beautiful world
building it's no wonder Black Panther
was a breakthrough hit the superhero
movie genre is mostly dominated by dudes
but the gender roles were finally
reversed in 2017 when the most iconic
female hero finally got her own movie
Wonder Woman was a critical success in a
box-office smash reinvigorating DC
superhero universe and giving kids a
different kind of hero to look up to in
a DC franchise that had up until then
been defined by grit and gloom this
Amazon princess emerged as a beacon of
courage and hope she isn't punching down
cities or branding bad guys
she's a protector of the people trying
to end all war unlike the DCE used
Batman or Superman
Diana actually cares about people and
sees the good in humanity she's more
concerned with saving lives than serving
justice Superman symbol might stand for
hope but it's Wonder Woman that restored
our faith and the power of superheroes
spider-man into the spider verse takes
the iconic web crawlers web slinging
mythos in exciting new directions by
introducing audiences to a vibrant world
of parallel dimensions parallel lives
and talking cartoon pigs you got a
problem with cartoon
the plot follows teenage Miles Morales
who's bitten by you guessed it's a
radioactive spider but things get even
more complicated when a powerful machine
opens up portals to other worlds
blasting a whole team's worth of
alternate universe spider people in two
miles as New York City
the film's brilliant animation captures
the feeling of reading in the comic
book-like view movies have before it it
couples the visuals with a daring story
that takes a daunting multiverse concept
and routes it in character moments that
any viewer can relate to young or old
most superhero movies are about special
people doing the impossible into the
spider versus a rare gem that makes you
feel like you can do the impossible -
2017 s Logan finally allowed Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine the r-rated chance
the slice and dices foes like Marvel's
own Freddy Krueger but the movie is so
much more than just an extra bloody
x-men adventure it's an ode to a hero at
the end of his life and a somber
meditation on violence regrets and
redemption inspired by classic westerns
in the old man Logan comic books
Logan stands apart from the rest of the
x-men series it takes the nearly
unkillable Wolverine and brings him back
down to earth as a broken forlorn mortal
man Jackman and co-star Patrick Stewart
gives some of the best performances of
their careers with stark portrayals of
their characters as dying men in a
defeated world their last mission is to
protect Laura a young clone of
Wolverines who still has hope for the
future the three leads surprisingly
familial connection makes a grounded and
emotional story that resonates in a way
few superhero movies can match that
happens to people I care about no sim
can obviously 2004's The Incredibles is
still one of the best superhero movies
and one of the best Pixar movies - it's
full of brilliant little moments that
stick in your memory like the hilarious
interviews that opened the film or the
macabre no capes montage there's also
the fact that this is a kids movie that
deals seriously with adult themes
characters go through midlife crises and
grapple with hiding their identities in
a world that won't accept them the
action sequences are fluid and fun just
as thrilling as almost anything you'll
see
a live-action Marvel or DC film but what
really elevates the movie is the family
at the center of the story who are
charming both at home and on the
battlefield they're also completely
believable as a family unit both of you
will get a grip or so help me I will
ground you for a month understand after
11 years and 21 films the Marvel
Cinematic Universe finally brought the
Infinity Saga to a close with endgame an
epic action flick that smashed
box-office records and said farewell to
some of our most beloved superheroes
despite running three hours long it
never feels its length with each act
feeling wildly different from the last
it all leads up to the most ambitious
superhero battle ever filmed featuring
dozens of characters from across the MCU
in a climactic battle for the fate of
the universe though it starts off with
the tone of mourning endgame ends up
feeling like an absolute joy its biggest
achievement is that it truly works as
the finale to a decade plus of
storytelling watching all of Marvel's
characters reunite one last time is
stirring
and while the MCU will likely continue
long past the original six Avengers
endgame provides the perfect conclusion
to their story as a team the granddaddy
of the MCU Iron Man is just as good
today as it was in 2008 with heavy
hitters like the x-men and spider-man
already sold off to larger Studios
Marvel had to pull heroes from the bench
to launch its shared universe Iron Man
was one of the best of the rest so
director Jon Favreau was given a lot of
freedom and the studio banked on the
charisma of Robert Downey jr. the gamble
worked and this movie managed to tell an
extremely fun story while setting the
tone for a massive twenty billion dollar
franchise to follow it's also a textbook
example of how to get a superhero origin
story right I am Iron Man
over the course of 10 years and 18 films
Marvel had been preparing for the most
ambitious crossover event in movie
history
and when it came time for the world's
mightiest heroes to fight the universe's
biggest bad guy the results were better
than anyone could have dreamed 2018 s
infinity war quickly became one of the
highest-grossing films of all time
integrating countless characters into a
cohesive world most importantly infinity
war totally delivered when it came to
the mad Titan who Marvel fans had been
eagerly awaiting since 2012 in a
surprising twist Marvel even made Thanos
the film's true protagonist and then the
mad Titan wins the day and one of the
gutsiest
endings in blockbuster history watching
so many beloved characters turned to
dust is absolutely heartbreaking but it
also set the stage for the climactic
finale to Hollywood's most successful
franchise hi I'm Steve Rogers the
pinnacle of the MCU was established
relatively early on with a first ever
team up of Earth's Mightiest Heroes in
the Avengers written and directed by fan
favorite Joss Whedon the result proved
an unqualified critical and commercial
hit a new universe it's one of the most
successful films ever made
pulling in more than 1.5 billion dollars
worldwide and it scored some of the best
reviews earned by any of the years wide
releases it's a comic book brought to
life in the best possible way and Whedon
managed to blend a bevy of characters
geek out fanservice and a compelling
story into one perfect package the
superhero movies genre was in its
infancy in 2004 but despite being
practically ancient spider-man 2 still
holds up this is a movie that features
an Evil Dead style horror sequence a
superhero showdown on a train the most
heartbreaking date ever filmed and a
villain who feels like an old-timey
Universal monster
none of this should fit together but it
all works perfectly
it does whatever a spider can means away
but spider-man 2 really shines by giving
us the most relatable superhero of all
time
unlike the mega-rich Batman or the
nearly immortal mutant Wolverine Peter
is just a normal guy trying to deliver
pizza and woo the girl of his dreams
while keeping the streets of New York
safe when he's not fighting
supervillains he's struggling with
everyday problems yeah he can shoot webs
and climb walls but this version of the
web crawler is still the most human
superhero we've ever seen the Dark
Knight isn't just the best superhero
movie ever made it assured in a new era
for comic book movies suddenly superhero
movies could be high art worthy of
awards and accolades all thanks to the
Caped Crusader and the Clown Prince of
Crime here was a film with one of the
greatest opening sequences of all time
it explored heavy concepts like what
people do when forced into terrible
circumstances and told the tragic story
of the rise and fall of Harvey Dent it
also featured the greatest 18-wheeler
flip of all time Heath Ledger won a
posthumous Oscar for his turn as the
Kaos loving Joker and all these years
later people still shudder when they
remember his freaky scars and his
terrifying magic trick it's a
performance for the ages
and thanks to ledger the Joker joined
the best cinematic villains alongside
Darth Vader and Hannibal Lecter with its
impressive acting pounding score
impeccable direction and intense action
The Dark Knight is the kind of superhero
movie that fans deserve and need
I'm just ahead of the curve check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite superhero movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]